♪ [upbeat music plays]
Dan Murray: Well, at WebFilings,
we produce software that helps a company
to streamline their SEC reporting process.
And it's been a really labor
intensive process for decades
using older tools, word processors,
and spreadsheet applications.
And so our product provides a web-based
word processor and spreadsheet application
that really helps to shave a lot
of time off the overall process.
Well, we started working with AppEngine
right after it launched in 2008.
And we were really excited about cloud computing
and what cloud computing was gonna
do just in general for software,
engineering software development.
And AppEngine really,
from the scalability perspective,
we knew, we were gonna grow very quickly
and we have to date grown
very fast over the past year.
And we looked at Google AppEngine's ability
to scale really predictably, linearly with load.
That was really important
in the beginning.
We also spent time looking at Google
and looking at Google AppEngine's
approach to security,
knowing that our customers really
wanted something that would be
really solid from a security
standpoint and very reliable
because the information that they're
producing has to be very accurate,
very timely, and it also--.
These companies are putting
pre-release financial information
into Google's cloud in GAE
through our product.
And so, you can imagine
if that information ever got out,
that it could be very, very harmful to customers.
So, we've taken a really strong
approach to security ourselves,
and then also just being
on the Google foundation
just gives us and our customers
peace of mind.
Google, with Google AppEngine's
provide a platform
that takes the infrastructure
management off of our hands.
We don't have to worry about it.
So, it's easy for us
to build and deploy apps.
And for us right now,
it's about execution and making sure
that we're scaling our business,
while AppEngine provides the ability
to scale technology and platform.
So the future for us is really
how do we evolve the product
and find new ways to help our customers
save time in areas of financial reporting?
00:02:22.750,00:00:00.000